- Thanks to CuriosityStream
for keeping Legal Eagle in the air,
which now comes with Nebula for free.
Link in the description.
The Supreme Court's decisions
on President Trump's tax returns are in.
Now, remember there is
no legal requirement
that presidential candidates
or presidents for that matter
release their tax returns
from any particular year.
But despite the lack of legal requirement
for the last 30 years,
almost all presidential and
vice presidential candidates
have released years of
their personal tax returns.
And during that time,
every person nominated for the president
as a Democrat or Republican
has released their tax information,
except for President Donald Trump.
The self-proclaimed billionaire
whose companies filed
for bankruptcy six times
has been extremely guarded about releasing
any information about
his financial status.
Well, he said he would release them.
- I will release my tax returns
against my lawyer's wishes.
I will absolutely give my return.
- But then decided not to.
- Well, I'm not releasing tax returns,
'cause, as you know, they're under audit.
- The financial information
supposedly revealed
that President Trump was deeply in debt
for much of the 1980s and 1990s,
and that he borrowed lots of
money from overseas entities,
and that in multiple years he
claimed more financial losses
than all but two other U.S. taxpayers.
Some people reacted to this
news with the phrase "So what?"
- You know, the only one that
cares about my tax returns
are the reporters, okay?
They're the only ones.
- While others believe
that the revelations
were just the tip of the iceberg.
But in 2018, the New York Times said
that they obtained years of financial data
about President Trump and
his various organizations
from anonymous sources,
which we now know include the
president's niece, Mary Trump,
who is writing her own
biography of the president.
But the state of New York
subpoenaed President
Trump's financial records
in connection with potentially
the campaign finance
violations that Michael Cohen,
the president's lawyer, has
already gone to jail over.
Meanwhile, in Congress,
three oversight committees of
the House of Representatives
has subpoenaed President
Trump's accounting firm
and multiple banks looking for information
about the president's financial history.
President Trump challenged
all of these subpoenas,
and the cases wound up
in the Supreme Court.
Although the cases
obviously include
President Trump directly,
the stakes go far beyond that
in the upcoming presidential election.
These decisions will determine
just how much power the
president, any president,
not just the sitting president,
has to control the legal process
against the presidency in the future.
And these cases are a mixed bag.
Everyone wins and everyone loses.
(news reel music)
Hey, Legal Eagles, it's
time to think like a lawyer
because it looks like some of
the president's information
is going to be disclosed
to district attorneys
and potentially the public.
The Supreme Court has just
decided two major cases
regarding the accessibility
of a sitting president's tax information
and financial records.
And what did they decide?
And what does this mean
for President Trump
and his upcoming bid for reelection?
Well, let's dive in and
get down to brass tacks.
This is a tale of two cases.
The very long 2020 Supreme Court term
has finally come to a close
with the Court finally resolving
the two cases involving Donald Trump's tax
and financial information.
So how did we get here?
Well, the president claims to
be a self-made billionaire.
- My father gave me a
very small loan in 1975,
and I built it into a company
that's worth many, many
billions of dollars.
- So why is it so taxing
for President Trump
to show his taxes?
Well, we don't know what, if anything,
the president is trying to
hide in breaking with precedent
and refusing to disclose his tax returns,
but that picture might
have been made clearer
when the New York Times published
a Pulitzer Prize-winning article entitled
"Trump Engaged in Suspect Tax Schemes
"as He Reaped Riches From His Father."
The article was a deep dive
into the finances of Donald Trump
and his father, Fred Trump Sr.,
as well as the rest of
his immediate family.
The article made two major findings.
First, President Trump
got a whole lot more
than a $1 million loan
from his father, Fred Trump,
as the president had always claimed.
Secondly, President Trump
along with his siblings
engaged in a variety of tax schemes
that many tax experts said were illegal.
It's a fascinating read
that definitely deserves
to be readdressed,
especially since we've sort of moved on
from this particular scandal.
But some of the highlights include
that not only did
President Trump dissemble
when he claimed that he only
received a $1 million loan
from his father to start his own business,
which he allegedly paid
back with interest,
The New York times discovered
that actually President
Trump's father loaned him north
of $60 million at the time or
$140 million in today's money.
And that he received at least
$413 million in today's money
from his father's estate,
much of which might have
been received by dubious
and potentially illegal tax schemes
he engaged in along with his siblings.
And these schemes included
potentially creating sham corporations
to disguise gifts from
President Trump's parents
to himself and his his siblings
to just undervaluing
several real estate holdings
in their parents' estate
to avoid paying more taxes
on those particular holdings.
And some in the Trump family
have already faced consequences
from The New York Times article.
For example, President Trump's
sister, Maryanne Trump Barry,
once a federal judge, was forced to retire
after the article disclosed
that she and her siblings
were co-owners of a shell company
that allegedly siphoned cash
from their father's business
by just making up purchases.
In addition, the inflated receipts
were allegedly used to
justify rent increases
for thousands of tenants.
Barry quit in order to stop a
judicial ethics investigation
into her conduct, though,
she did get to keep her $200,000 pension.
On the other hand, the
president has managed
to escape scrutiny of his own taxes,
largely by stonewalling the
House and district attorneys
who are asking for that
financial information.
And, as a result, at this time the public
can't be certain that the
president is either guilty
or innocent of these allegations,
which takes us to the
two Supreme Court cases
that were just decided.
The first is captioned
as Trump versus Vance.
Vance in this case being the famous,
some would say infamous,
New York district Attorney Cy Vance.
Now I know it seems like ancient history,
but you might recall
that the president's old
lawyer, Michael Cohen,
went to prison for tax evasion
and violating campaign finance law.
His crimes were paying an adult
film star, Stormy Daniels,
and former Playboy model, Karen McDougal,
to stay quiet about their
alleged sexual encounters
with President Trump.
Now there's no way to know for sure,
but it's possible that President Trump
was the unindicted
co-conspirator individual one
who engaged in a conspiracy
with Michael Cohen.
Of course, the name has been redacted,
so it's impossible to know for certain
that President Trump was in
fact individual number one.
But not withstanding, the
district attorney for New York,
Cyrus Vance, subpoenaed Trump's
accounting firm Mazars USA
for eight years of business
and personal tax records
in connection with President Trump
and the Trump organization's
potential role
in the hush money payments
made to McDougal and Daniels
before the 2016 election.
This is a criminal investigation
into President Trump's possible role
in these violations of
law, since Cohen claimed
to be acting on President Trump's behalf.
- I am ashamed that I chose to take part
in concealing Mr. Trump's illicit acts
rather than listening
to my own conscience.
- The president filed for
emergency injunctive relief,
claiming that as president
the constitution provides him
with absolute immunity
from any criminal
process or investigation,
including unofficial presidential conduct
and the associated subpoenas
of third party records.
This means that President
Trump thinks he has a right
to stop Mazars and the
banks Vance also subpoenaed
from complying with the subpoenas.
And as a result of the injunction,
those financial records
were never turned over
to the state of New York.
So let's talk about President
Trump's arguments here.
President Trump argued
that now is not the time
to bring any potential
criminal charges against him.
In the president's view,
there are only two options
for dealing with criminal allegations
against a current president.
One, Congress can impeach the president,
which we've crossed that bridge,
or a state can launch a
criminal investigation
after he or she ends
their term as president.
The president contended that
defending a criminal inquiry
would interfere with his ability
to discharge his duties as president,
and he asserted that criminal charges
are actually prohibited
by the Supremacy Clause
of Article II of the Constitution
since state and local officials
are simply using their authority to
"defeat the legitimate operations
"of the federal government."
The president argued that it's
not necessarily this one case
that would distract him
from presidential duties.
Rather it is "the cumulative effect
"of permitting every
state and local prosecutor
"to take the same steps the
district attorney did here."
And while the president
was making it sound like
there are thousands of local prosecutors
waiting to prosecute the president,
really he was arguing
sort of the same thing
that Bill Clinton once did
in Clinton versus Jones
that any action taken against
him would also ipso facto
be politically motivated and
would swamp the presidency
in responding to all of
these different inquiries.
Some of which might be legitimate,
but the vast majority of
which might not be legitimate
and might be filed by
Democratic district attorneys
to stymie a Republican president
or Republican district attorneys
to stymie a Democratic president.
In response, District
Attorney Vance simply said
that there's no such thing
as unlimited presidential immunity
from criminal prosecution.
Vance argued persuasively
that the president's Article II immunity
only extends to official acts
in his capacity as president.
And prior precedent
involving sitting presidents
like Clinton versus Jones
and Nixon versus Fitzgerald
bolstered Vance's arguments.
When Paula Jones sued Bill
Clinton for sexual harassment
that happened before he was president,
the Court ruled that he was not entitled
to absolute immunity from civil litigation
arising out of events
which transpired prior
to his taking office.
And that lawsuit was not dismissed,
and Clinton had to comply
with the legal process.
Eventually he sat for a deposition,
which he famously perjured himself.
And on the other hand,
the Supreme Court has ruled in
the past that President Nixon
did have absolute immunity from damages
predicated on his official
acts as president.
Things that happened
while he was the president
of the United States.
But even in that case, the
Supreme Court emphasized
that a president is not
immune from criminal charges
stemming from his official
or unofficial acts while in office.
And here Vance argued
the same limitation on
presidential immunity
also extends to the Supremacy Clause,
which supposedly prevented states
from interfering in the
president's official acts.
Vance argued that state
criminal investigations
and subsequent subpoenas
are both unrelated to the
president's official acts
and would not interfere
with President Trump's official duties
as president of the United States.
And Vance also pointed out
that allowing a president
to have total immunity
from criminal or civil litigation
during the time the president is in office
could lead to total immunity
after one's presidential term has ended,
as well as immunity from third parties.
Because if that immunity existed,
it might impede the criminal investigation
because you might lose the evidence
or the statute of limitations might run
because too much time has passed.
So let's talk about how
the Supreme Court ruled
in this particular case.
Here, Vance won and Trump
lost, at least on paper.
The Supreme court ruled
seven justices to two
that in our judicial system
"the public has a right
to every man's evidence."
In practice, this means that the president
does not have absolute immunity
from state criminal subpoenas.
And state prosecutors do not
need to meet a higher standard
to seek evidence from a sitting president.
Although President Trump argued
that criminal cases would
distract him from his job,
Justice Roberts disagreed stating,
"two centuries of experience confirm
"that a properly tailored
criminal subpoena
"will not normally hamper the performance
"of the President's
constitutional duties."
And one of the things that
led to people thinking
that this was a complete
slam dunk of a case
is that these subpoenas
weren't directed at the president himself,
but rather third parties,
accountants and banks.
So it's not like the president
was going to have to spend
all of his time responding
to the subpoenas anyway.
These records are held by third parties,
and President Trump cannot
tell those third parties
that they can't respond.
And although President Trump argued
that criminal investigations
would harm the public perception of him,
the majority opinion
also dismissed this claim
by noting that the issuance of a subpoena
would not have much of an effect
on the president's reputation.
Because when you get a subpoena,
you have to provide the information.
There's no necessary stigma
related to that in particular.
Moreover, grand jury proceedings,
like what was going on in New York,
are strictly confidential,
which, as the court pointed out,
should prevent the very stigma
that the president anticipates.
Chief Justice Roberts, who
wrote the opinion of the Court,
also dismissed the president's concern
about thousands of local prosecutors
trying to make a name for themselves
by investigating the president.
The court pointed out
that the legal system
already has safeguards to protect against
the abuse of prosecutors
that the president envisions.
And while it's true that
the Supremacy Clause
bars local officials
from interfering with
the president's duties,
if a prosecutor is attempting
to usurp the president
rather than simply investigate a crime,
then the president can
challenge that in court,
which is exactly what President
Trump did in this case.
And while the president and
the Department of Justice
argued that state prosecutors
should be subject to a higher standard
in order to get evidence
from the president,
the Supreme Court disagreed
holding that it would not be proper
for state criminal subpoenas
to be subject to a higher standard.
And the broader point was that,
"the public interest in fair
and effective law enforcement
"cuts in favor of comprehensive
access to evidence."
So if state grand juries had
to meet a higher standard,
it would, "hobble the grand jury's ability
"to acquire all information
that might possibly bear
"on its investigation."
The Court also echoed Vance's concern
that the evidence would be
lost if prosecutors had to wait
until the end of the
president's term to see it.
At the end in this first
case, Trump versus Vance,
the Court remanded the case
back to the lower court of
appeals for additional argument.
In that argument President Trump
can make new arguments about the subpoenas
and try to prevent the
subpoenas from being enforced.
But he can't argue that he is immune
or that a higher standard should apply.
While there are still
legal questions to decide,
President Trump is probably
going to lose most,
if not all of the battles that
he is going to have to fight
in the court of appeals.
So while the biggest battle
is over, the war is not.
And President Trump will probably
continue to make arguments
that these specific
subpoenas are overbroad
or make other smaller arguments
about why they shouldn't be enforced.
So it's possible that this
issue will not be resolved
before the 2020 election.
Though, since this was a
grand jury proceeding anyway,
it wasn't going to be open
to the public in any event.
Which takes us to the other tax case
that was decided at the same
time, Trump versus Mazars.
While Trump versus Vance was
a defeat for the president,
Trump versus Mazars some argue
that the president prevailed,
at least because he's
going to delay the effect
of the decision, at least for now.
This case was kicked
off when President Trump
sought injunctive relief on four subpoenas
issued by three separate house committees:
the House Financial Services Committee,
the House Intelligence Committee,
and the House Oversight Committee.
These subpoenas were sent to
Trump's accounting firm again,
as well as to financial
institutions he used
for personal and business reasons.
The goal of these subpoenas
according to the House committees
is to exercise their
basic roles of oversight
in legislative responsibilities.
Now, how would this information be used?
Well, the committee said
it would inform Congress
on subjects like whether they need
to impose new international
money laundering restrictions
to evaluate current ethics
laws for presidents,
or determine if it should be mandatory
to have future presidents
disclose their tax returns.
And obviously it goes without saying
that it might inform past and
future impeachment inquiries.
Now, Donald Trump argued
that congressional committees
are only authorized
to issue subpoenas for a
true legislative agenda,
not for any law enforcement reason.
That would be the purview
of the executive branch exclusively.
And President Trump also
made the very broad claim
of executive privilege stating that,
"Whatever powers Congress holds,
"it may not deploy them in a
way that keeps the President
"from fulfilling the
obligations of his office."
Now the House of Representatives argued
that this matter had already been decided
citing Clinton versus Jones
in which a sitting president
was not immune from civil litigation.
The House committees argued that,
"Article II does not
confer on a president,
"the power to resist compulsory
process directed at him,"
unless "there is impairment
of the Executive's ability
"to perform its constitutionally
mandated functions."
The House committees argued
that this is clearly not
the case in this situation
since the subpoenas were not
even directed at the president.
So there's no actual burden
on the president himself.
Congress argued that it
has the legislative purpose
for seeking information if
a subpoena seeks information
that will inform Congress on a subject
that would likely lead to legislation.
Well, detractors argued that
these assertions were so broad
that it would allow the House
to seek personal
information from a president
about anything if it somehow
could be used to justify a law.
The Supreme Court ruled seven to two
in a way that sort of splits
things down the middle.
The Court did reject
President Trump's claim
that he can raise executive
privilege over the information
and did acknowledge that
Congress has the power
to subpoena information from the president
so it can craft legislation effectively.
However, the Supreme
Court limited that power
and held that congressional
subpoenas are valid
only they serve a "valid
legislative purpose"
and are not intended to be
law enforcement efforts.
And the Supreme Court for the first time
articulated a four-part test
to determine if the
subpoenas can be enforced
against the executive branch.
But just as it did in the Vance case,
the Supreme Court rejected
President Trump's argument
that Congress needs to prove
that the records are critical
or some incredibly high standard.
Applying such a high standard
here Robert's explained,
again, he wrote the opinion
for the Supreme Court,
"would risk seriously impeding Congress
"in carrying out its responsibilities."
But the Court also dismissed
arguments by the House
that these subpoenas
should be treated like
any other request for documents.
The Court held that the House
did not take into account
"the significant
separation of powers issues
"raised by congressional subpoenas
"for the president's information,"
and articulated that when lower courts
have to decide whether to
enforce a congressional subpoena
into records involving the
president, the courts should
"perform a careful analysis
that takes adequate account
"of the separation of
powers principles at stake."
Among other things, courts should consider
whether the president's
papers are really necessary,
because the information
cannot be obtained elsewhere,
whether the subpoena is as
limited in scope as it can be
while still serving Congress's power,
what evidence Congress
has offered to establish
that a subpoena advances a
valid legislative purpose,
and what burdens a subpoena
imposes on the president.
And because the lower courts
did not adequately consider these factors,
probably because these factors
didn't exist before
the Supreme Court case,
the cases will now return to those courts
for additional proceedings.
So there were two crucial questions posed
by the Vance and Mazars cases.
First, can of state subpoena
a current president's personal records
as part of a criminal investigation?
And the answer to that is yes,
a state prosecutor has the right
to subpoena a sitting president
or third parties who hold information
about the current president.
And those inquiries are not bound
by any kind of higher burden
than would normally happen
under a state investigation.
And the second question
was whether Congress
can subpoena a president's
personal information
outside of a formal impeachment inquiry?
And the answer is basically yes,
but although Congress may have the right
to subpoena personal
information about the president,
it will need to show that there is really
a legislative purpose for the information,
and Congress can't necessarily
do a fishing expedition
into the president's personal information.
In the end, the Court
affirmed that the president
is not above the law,
but the justices also kick the can
down the road a little longer,
pretty much guaranteeing
that we won't see the
president's financial records
before the vote in November.
Now I have a lot more to say
about the political
implications of these decisions
and what it means in terms
of the public actually getting
access to the tax returns,
but that's probably not safe for YouTube,
which is why I put my
extended discussion on Nebula.
My creator friends and I teamed
up to build our own platform
where creators don't need to worry
about demonetization or
the dreaded algorithm.
It's called Nebula,
and we're thrilled to be
partnering with CuriosityStream,
because Nebula is a place
where creators can do
what they do best, create.
It's a place where we can
both house our content ad-free
and also experiment with original content
and a new series that probably
wouldn't work on YouTube.
In fact, if you liked this episode,
the version that I put up on
Nebula removes this ad entirely
and replaces it with
that extended discussion
about the president's tax returns
and all of the implications there.
The bar has been set so low
that rejecting these
incredibly stupid arguments
is considered a win.
Nebula features lots of YouTube's
top educationalist
creators, like Thomas Frank,
Knowing Better, Polyphonic,
and Lindsay Ellis,
and tons of others.
We also get to collaborate in ways
that wouldn't work on YouTube,
like Tom Scott's amazing
game show "Money,"
where he pits a bunch of famous
YouTubers against each other
in psychological experiments
where they can work together
or profit individually.
It is amazing, you will love it.
So what does this have to
do with CuriosityStream?
Well, as the go-to source
for the best documentaries
on the internet,
they love educational content
and educational creators.
And we worked out a deal
where if you sign up for CuriosityStream
with the link in the description,
not only will you get
access to CuriosityStream,
but you'll also get a Nebula
subscription for free.
And to be clear, that Nebula
subscription is not a trial.
It's free for as long as you
are a CuriosityStream member.
And for a limited time,
CuriosityStream is offering
26% off their annual plans.
That's less than $15 a year
for both CuriosityStream and Nebula.
Less than $15.
It's incredible.
And since you've got to stay inside,
you might as well be soothed
by the voice of David
Attenborough narrating tales
about tiny hummingbirds,
or join Chris Hadfield on a
road trip through the universe,
or just watch Tom Scott
torture your favorite YouTubers on Nebula.
So if you click on the
link in the description,
you'll get both CuriosityStream
and Nebula for 26% off,
or you can go to
CuriosityStream.com/LegalEagle.
It's a great way to support this channel
and educational content directly
for just $14.79 per year.
That's 26% off.
So just click on the
link in the description
or go to CuriosityStream.com/LegalEagle.
Clicking on that link really
helps out this channel.
So what do you think about
the Court's decisions?
And do you think that there
should be a federal law
requiring presidential candidates
to reveal their tax returns?
Leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other real law reviews
talking about the protests and
COVID-related legal issues.
There's a lot going on in the law.
So click on this video
and I'll see you in court.